amkoullel l'enfant peul qui paraît aux
éditions actes sud
ce sont les souvenirs d'enfance un
extraordinaire personnage amadou hampate
ba cet homme de sagesse était né vers
1900 à bandiagara au mali un haut lieu
de la civilisation dogon et y est mort
forte âgées au printemps dernier il
avait été membre du conseil exécutif de
l'unesco et conseiller du président de
la côte d'ivoire félix houphouët boigny
j'ai rencontré hampate ba dans sa
modeste maison d'abidjan où il recevait
avec chaleur et simplicité
ces visiteurs du monde entier il n'était
pas seulement l'auteur d'un merveilleux
roman picaresque vent grain sorte de
robin des bois de la brousse c'était un
homme de mémoire et l'on sait
l'importance que celle ci revêt en
afrique
il est très difficile à un africain de
résumé écrit hampate ba dans son avant
propos
on raconte en totalité on ne raconte pas
on ne se lasse jamais d'entendre ou de
réentendre les mêmes histoires pour nous
la répétition n'est pas un défaut telle
est en cours elle long et détaillé
aventures d'une jeunesse et d'un esprit
en formation entre la tradition
africaine et la colonisation française
c'est un témoignage qui n'a pas
d'équivalent